hey guys ryan right here and Jerry over
here we just sat down and found out from
my lovely sexy hot ass girlfriend
Veronica six toes right who has an
acoustic cover channel and there she
informed us that we had just passed
300,000 subscribers oh [ __ ] you know
what that means what we're more popular
we are in Oh Brian a clue that's great
now a lot of the time people take me
thanks baby by a lot of time people take
these like Thank You videos to thank the
subs I want to take this time to thank
us because you guys wouldn't have
subscribe to anything if we didn't
create the content first to begin with
so you're welcome you're welcome oh all
three hundred thousand of you haven't
been kind kind and only a few thousand
you will actually watch this video
because it's not a reaction well we're
reacting to the fig just put a video of
the I'm gonna record a video of the
figures right now thanks man yeah yeah
all right this was supposed to be one
take and you're making skull way to all
right now I am headed around this do I
really want to do that no I don't listen
I wanted to make an announcement in this
video though one announcement um I
wanted to start doing this there's so
many requests for videos to like check
out and review them so many requests I
know only the dedicated fans are going
to tune in for this thank you video so
you dedicated fans this is December 2015
last month of December put down your
request last month of December and
that's about the last year of the year
put out your request and put down what
what I would like for you guys to
request this video's that would generate
a reaction but also a review or
discussion yeah if it's just a reaction
I'm not going to be that interested in
it and also anime we can't do that too
many people were kidding copyright
strikes them getting their channels
threatened to be shut down because it
would do it too much adamant you know
who I'm talking and I mean preferably
talking about nothing that involves
human cruelty yeah or real life peril
would be late Oh real life peril yeah
I'm not a fan of that but human cruelty
can be funny sometimes watching this get
gross down can be fun well you get it's
like a filthy Frank video then like sure
exactly and um also I just want to say
we got some stuff in the pipeline I keep
saying that but we really are going
gung-ho with it yeah we've got pipeline
we opened up a pipe or importing oils
official we are an oil company now yeah
that was the dream all welcome to the
real rejects the most proud perverted
oil company you'll ever find yeah get
your car serviced um listen I want to
see who the lucky guy is who gets a
shout out today in this video oh man how
is the lucky guy because of the shoutout
page guys um let's give a shout out to
UM irmak och goon chose the wrong guy
hurry tell by his name hey right can I
get a shout-out first of all I recommend
your channel to everyone in my country
Venezuela no I don't think so Pakistan
Germany turkey Turkey you are a funny
guy people love it and I absolutely love
it you are awesome anyways a question
would you consider doing porn if you got
a one-million-dollar proposal you sick
twisted funny sexuality man i would pay
to watch that irmak our money you know
right now that that is a scary question
to answer when said girlfriend is
sitting in my peripheral but if it's
porn then it's just business you know
it's just do it another form that's one
way to look at it Jerry later another
way to look at it is you lose a
relationship Dorothy answer you give um
how about you ask him what if it's a
soft core point he doesn't stipulate
what if it's a Jewish porn but if he
just has to jerk off on King Muslim
porno have you not considered the idea
us doing a porn together dude and then
you would like you register to bird two
birds with one stone that's your sex
tape and you get extra famous two birds
with one stone that's the name of the
video there's gonna be another person
involved for Veronica she doesn't want
me to do anything with the other person
she's gonna tie me up against the chair
and take my eyes wide open so I have to
watch her make love to this other guy
this is like a [ __ ] work orange yeah dan
Seibert day three you guys on the chance
really funny in that orgy vine anyway
our mock you tell all your Turkish
friends I said thank you Turkey's a
wonderful country it's a good they
provide us with the best meet you guys
give us like such goods don't make stuff
organic or gross your nerdy you're not
fully vers debt know turkeys where we
get our turkey from like foster farm
turkey that's deli fresh true that's
yeah the people i von't said they get it
from Turkey this is a great joke I'm so
happy originality that's what we offer
on the real rejects put down your
request people will catch you on the
flipside